Speaker 1: Okay. One other really quick note
here at Trump's previous rally in Ohio. We had
this crazy thing where he starts playing dramatic
music while he talks about how terrible things are
in the U.S. And a lot of people in the crowd did a
one finger salute. And we didn't know whether the
idea was that it's a Nazi salute, except they're
doing one finger instead of the flat hand so it
doesn't look the same or whether it's a Q and on
salute because Q and on has this WW one you know
you guys know the thing okay. So it turns out
it's a cute ending and the Trump people caught
wind that it doesn't look great for there to be
Q and on salutes happening at Trump rallies. So
when they started playing the dramatic conspiracy
music at Trump's latest rally in Wilmington, North
Carolina, security actually went through the crowd
telling people to put down their hands. It was
very, very interesting. And there's a couple of
different posts about this. In this one, you see
one guy with an American flag shirt with the one
finger thing, and then you see these security
people going through the crowd. And it was widely
reported that they were telling all those people
to put their hands down, to put their fingers down
that they didn't want to see that. We actually
have a video of this happening as well. And this
is while Donald Trump is speaking and you see some
of these people with their fingers up and then you
start to see the security people go through the
crowd and saying, put your finger down, put your
finger down. You see these people go through hands
down, hands down, hands down, a bunch of them,
and then the fingers come down. They clearly have
realized that it doesn't look particularly good
for this to be happening because it's a Q and on
salute. Now, what's really funny is initially the
reaction was they're just saying we're number one.
Of course, that doesn't make any sense because
they're saying we're number one. Supposedly
during the part of the speech where Trump talks
about how terrible the country has become. So why
would they decide to say we're number one? While
Trump is talking about our airports are terrible.
You know, crime is rampant. The economy's
terrible. Our leaders, everything's terrible. Oh,
yeah, we're number one. That doesn't make
any sense. So then now they're implicitly
admitting that it is not a salute that is just
were number one, because security goes through
the crowd when the fingers come up and they say,
you got to put those fingers down. Just a little
note for everybody. On that particular issue, it
was never the truth that they believed that they
were just saying, we're number one. Ever, ever,
ever. It's a Q and on salute. It looks bad. And
now they're having their literal brownshirts. It's
an extra security force that was Brownshirts. Go
through the crowd and say, put the fingers down.
These rallies have become completely dystopian.